good afternoon councillors welcome along
for this meeting of the performance
policy and partnerships committee the
live stream has begun
[Music]
we have a uh
councillor arnold and councillor abbott
joining us on zoom councillor arnold's
there councillor abbott was just feeling
a little unwell he may join us in the
near future we have apologies from
councillor clark mrs coote councillor
kit and councillor crack it which
thank you councilman
pottinger and councillor sober put that
all in favor against
carried
we've got uh one item in the public
forum and that relates to the agenda
item coming up around the northwood
avenue richfield drive renaming
consultation andrea welcome along come
and if you'd like to come and take a
seat
hello
do i sit down yep thanks for joining us
uh you get to take your mask off while
you're talking to us you've got
basically we allow 10 minutes for you to
feedback and in that time if you want to
leave a little bit at the end for
councils to ask questions that would be
useful as well but essentially the floor
is yours okay hi i'm andrea mcwilliam
the nominated spokesperson for the seven
affected properties
in northwood avenue regarding the
proposal to change our end of the avenue
into richfield drive
as you will have read from the seven
submissions we residents are strongly
opposed to their changing of our street
name
we do not believe it is necessary as
there is still a logical break point
between the end of northwood avenue and
the end of ritual drive with the
existing square cul-de-sac remains or
slash car parking area which delimits
this
all that is needed is adequate signage
we are all long-term residents with most
of us choosing to purchase
and build property where we did
because it was a quiet cul-de-sac
obviously that has since been taken away
from us
and with the opening up of richfield
drive
which um has subsequently caused intric
increased traffic flow and safe safety
concerns as outlined in some of our
submissions
and as outlined also to the council
delegation that met with us
so we ask that you do not impose even
greater inconvenience to us all by
changing our addresses and the resulting
hassles
it will cause us all for many years to
come
we therefore respectfully implore that
the councillors adopt your own council
officer's recommendation of maintaining
this status quo that is retaining our
addresses as northwood avenue thank you
thanks andrea quick question from me
before i throw it open to councillors
you do realize that uh changes to
roading layout are actually with the
developer not council uh we've found
yeah we obviously didn't never got
consulted on that so that was obviously
um a given the developer didn't need to
okay thank you uh councillors it's open
for any other questions for andrea
miss cook um a comment more than a
question i hope although um
framing it as a question uh mr chair
you are aware though that this is not
the first time that street names have
been changed um
i'm sort of one of the more elderly
people sitting here so i remember when
queen's drive was alice road north and
ellis road when bigger street and
balmoral drive with both bigger streets
all those sorts of things all the people
who lived in those places tend to accept
change
why
do you think we should take more
seriously
the fact that you will be uncomfortable
if something changed
well my answer to that is we're also
aware that there's a lot of street now
names out there that haven't been
changed so you're saying there is some
yes we acknowledge that we also
acknowledge there is quite a few around
the city that are in our same positions
and they've never been changed
so
one of the reasons and outlined in some
of the submissions is that if there's
signage to say there's richfield drive
from
the end of the oval as such
then
um we will get a lot more most people
that will be the first entrance to
richfield drive that they will see no
matter which end of it they want to go
to so i'll drive down our little bit of
legend which obviously was never
designed originally to be a thoroughfare
you only have to if you visited the
street you would see
that it was never designed to be a
thoroughfare there's already concerns
with the traffic from tradies and
of safety concerns in there so if it is
to be richfield drive right from that
entrance point
all the people visiting richfield drive
will drive in from that way and not the
other way
or make it even worse so that's one of
the reasons
thank you
any further questions
if not thanks for coming in and speaking
on behalf of the residents as i say we
do have their submissions in there which
is an item an item coming up in the
agenda later on thank you very much
thank you
could somebody let ollie know that the
youth councillors can come in please
welcome if you want to grab the two
seats from the priests table they're not
here
oh no there's only three of us
welcome along to the new cheers
co-chairs of the youth council in your
new roles your first meeting and coming
along to ppp
uh we've got a a copy of the report uh
from ollie and
gemma's on zoom as well essentially at
this point um we hand the floor over to
you welcome ah thank you councillor
uh good afternoon councillors your
worship and manofenua
my name is ryan frost and i'm a student
at vernon college i have been elected
one of the two co-chairs for youth
council 2020. hello and i'm lydia
blomfield and i'm from james hargis and
i am the other co-counselor welcome
cheers sorry for this year
um kia ora i'm katyana simpson also from
verodin our youth council has selected
two deputy chairs this year one of which
is myself and the other is nazia amelia
who unfortunately cannot be here today
i take our
youth council
report as read
and we are just going to go over a few
of the points in the report
so as you know youth council formed a
submission committee for the speed
review
and we attended the hearings on the 22nd
of march
um it was an excellent opportunity to
develop an opinion on something that we
were very passionate about and to be
engaged in the consultation for youth
council and
to also help represent
the youth in invercargill as well so
we're very we were very happy with that
opportunity
this year youth council implemented
the single transferable voting system as
a way to run our chairperson's elections
uh this is a method that the previous uh
youth council from last year decided on
and it's something that youth council
has previously engaged with before
we decided this would be a more
representative solution
of finding the best
chairs to represent the youth council
this year youth council decided to
change its operational structure uh we
made the decision to amalgamate um our
unders and over his meetings into one
combined meeting after the entire
duration of youth council this year
we deemed that it was not necessary to
have two separate meetings before our
combined meeting as it weren't the
necessary demographics to support it um
there were not
[Music]
um a large number of
younger members that would fit into
their unders category uh so we thought
it would be more suitable just to have a
combined meeting
uh will from uin youth was one of our
three speakers at our last meeting and
he asked if we wanted to hold another
uin youth regional hui again for 2022
this is a fabulous opportunity to get
the youth voice
out and heard at government level i'm
glad to say that the youth council
agreed to continue to work with them to
support this important mahi
youth council has decided their
committees for 2022 and we use the first
past the post-voting system for this
selection i'm most looking forward to
the mental health well-being committee
as youth these days we do struggle with
mental health quite often so i think
that this will make a real great
difference in the area and while we're
on the topic of uh brightening the world
i would like to show off our new council
badges very flash very flash get a load
of that
uh youth council this year does not
intend to report to uh every ppp
um meeting unless we have something
substantive to talk on
we encourage council to be proactive in
seeking a youth opinion where are on
topics where they view it to be relevant
thank you for your time and we look
forward to working
with you this year thank you thank you
congratulations on your appointment uh
congratulations on an outstanding
submission to the speed by law review i
look forward to reflecting on that with
you at your meeting tomorrow
um and and also for how you've outlined
your
ambitions for for 2022. uh
council certainly looks forward to
working with you councillors open for
questions or comments councillor lewis
thank you chair you want to pull that
microphone and graham thank you very
much
thank you very much for your
presentation one thing i'm quite
interested at the moment the mental
health aspect you you guys are of a
much older age than the primary schools
do you think it would be useful to have
a program starting at the primary school
age
for mental health
yes i believe that would be quite
valuable i think people can go through
all sorts of different
horrible mental problems from the very
youngest of ages whether that's in the
home or in the wider community i think
everyone can struggle at any age so i
feel like that would be very valuable
sure thank you very much for that
response counselor partner yeah thank
you chair uh again i like to follow on
about the
mental well-being and and
and especially note that um
states here following a facebook poll of
all members
yet um
mental well-being cyber bullying would
have to be one of the you know main
main causes of
of stress for young people yet the
facebook poll was used to
to get uh you know your sort of
um votes on what were the things so
obviously facebook has it's good
side but then it's other side have
can you can you enlighten this committee
on
any steps or
or advisement you may put forward to
to youth
for this side of um
mental well-being just just while they
pause to think about their answer there
it's worth pointing out it was it's a
private group
oh yeah
right
yeah uh so our little facebook group was
purely for us um students to go into so
it's quite a safe little environment
however yeah i completely understand
what you're saying um facebook and other
social media platforms are
one of the most easiest ways someone can
attack another person without being
overly seen or
like looked upon so i think for
youth um youth and actually everyone we
should be looking at
when people are reaching you out on
social media because that they're not
putting a face to the words that they
say i think the best thing to do is to
confront that person and let it be known
in an outer circle so someone else could
hopefully help you with it or just try
to block them and
get them out from speaking to you
because their words mean nothing when
they message them you know it's not
coming from a mouth you're reading them
yourself so it hurts more so it needs to
be tackled and looked at no thanks for
that
could i overwork
yes lindsey
thank you for that um and
congratulations to you all for your
appointments um you mentioned in your
report two methods of voting the
stb and the first past the post
i'm just interested to know that um
with the stv was it complicated was it
lengthy was it easy to understand and
you're happy with the result
uh yes from what i've heard from the
youth council coordinators
at first it took um
a wee bit to understand but after
they
had
looked into it a bit more it became
relatively
easy
i know that
jimmy managed to organise an online
accounting software which aided in
the whole mass of it and made it quite
clear
of um who
were the pointed chairs so i think yes
it was a effective method and wasn't too
difficult to use after the initial
hurdle of driving out so having used
both which would you prefer as a
committee
um well in my personal opinion i believe
that um
stv would is it is a preferable system
but sometimes it also depends in my view
the sort of things that are being
voted on
depending if it's
a wide range of things and
the number of people voting
if it's say
a relatively small group of people
voting
on something there is many options i
think svt
is a better option because that way you
get a better representation of
what most people would prefer
okay thanks for those thoughts gemma is
there anything is the chief counter that
you'd like to add
um so yeah we did the behind the scenes
which was great uh but i think
and i'd love to ask the youth counselor
if i throw a question back um to them
but did you find actually selecting your
peers and ranking them that process of
actually voting through stp easy
yes it was
not something that was
very
difficult
yep good thanks
your worship
yes and i add my congratulations to
those of councillor ludlow
uh
i was bailed up outside the admin
building here
uh over the issue of climate change
and it was
quite a passionate discussion we had
but um
of course now we're looking at wetland
fires
is there any action you're involved in
looking at
in terms of climate change
um
as one of our select committees we have
a united nations sustainable development
goals and climate change is going to be
a very big part of what that committee
does and we are hoping to look at
many things
to help invercargill and youth and
invicable with climate change and
education and climate change
thank you
thank you any further questions
councilor sopa
thanks mr chair
first of all congratulations on the
mature decision to use stv
and i'm sure you'll find once having
used it that you'll choose that way
again
i was just going to ask about the uin
youth hui
so there was an invitation to
councillors last year to attend
and i did attend and very much enjoyed
it so could you please
ensure that we know for this year when
it's going to be i think there would be
others who would like to come along as
well definitely we would definitely love
to
talk to you about that yeah great thank
you
how are the questions
if not i'll move that the report's
received is there a second
let's cook we'll put that all in favor
against
carrie thank you very much for your
presentation of coming along this
afternoon and we'll catch you tomorrow
thank you
council is the next item on the agenda
is the minutes of the community
well-being fund committee councillor
lewis thank you very much george i'd
like to move though the record is a true
and accurate record of the meeting that
we had
well
thank you very much and i'd like to as
always thank the staff for
lots of preparation they do
making it my job a lot easier for that
committee
it would be easier for you
rather than look so i'd like to thank
the staff for all the work they do in
the preparation
thank you
it's been moved and seconded any
questions or comments
if not i'll put that all in favor
against
carried
we've got the minutes from the
extraordinary meeting of performance
policy and partnerships on march 22nd
move councillor amundsen seconded
councillor partner
i beg your pardon
i have jumped ahead
from the are you comfortable with that
from the 8th of march councillors
thank you
any questions or comments arising from
that
if not i'll put the emotional in favor
against
carried
this time to the uh 18th
22nd
moved councillor uh pottinger and miss
cook
questions or comments
put the emotional in favor
aye against
carried um just following on from uh
public forum i'll ask councils the
committee's indulgence
and we'll jump to item nine which is the
uh northwood avenue richfield drive
consultation report before we do the
covert 19
pandemic response so uh rhiannon welcome
along to the meeting
cura councillors
um so i'll take the report as read um
the consultation was undertaken with the
members of the community directly
impacted
um
and it's the recommendation of offices
that on balance given the strength of
opinion of those community members who
are living on that section of northwood
avenue and richfield drive
that
those opinions should be taken into
account
and the option two
would be an appropriate option for
council to select
while option one was the preferred
option because from a logical point of
view and for the use of
people finding the street who don't live
there that might have an improvement
um it is a road that is um
not
travelled by a large number of people
and as a result um we recommend that the
views of residents outweigh that benefit
um
so i'm happy to take any questions
thank you before we fire off the
discussion we need some motions on the
table councillor lewis
i'm quite happy to move those
recommendations with private discussion
happy to second that mr chair thank you
do you have a comment you already have a
question if i may not have a comment if
i might share the change of the terms
avenue and drive i think are quite
important because we've had the
situation arise before
in gururi
and i saw not in very i'm
not going to be here anyway
it's got her
where there was some confusion
perceived with the same names drive
avenue on the same
route name so i think this is a sensible
decision to have the
the ritual drive completely separate
separate from norfolk avenue that's a
given anyway but i think the resident's
concern i think should be upheld and i
would actually vote in that favor
in that way
thank you any other comments councillor
pottinger
yeah look i i totally agree with with
the staff's recommendation um
your actual identity with your street
number and and name is important they
they bought the sections and the premise
that there was going to be a cul-de-sac
that's been taken away from them
um
as mentioned uh by the submitter the
demarcation between
richfield drive and the end of the
cul-de-sac is clear
it's it's it makes sense to start a new
a new road there so i'm fully supportive
of the
submissions from the residents and that
the status quo remains thank you
anyone else
if not it's been moved and seconded i'll
put the motion all in favor aye aye
against
carried
keep your name
castles that brings us to
tear bait which is the covert 19
pandemic response update
the report has read the purpose of this
report is about sensible housekeeping
and record keeping and archiving so this
is
the follow-up to the delegated decision
report that we made a little while ago
and this is just capturing what happened
uh and also a moment in time just to
update everyone where we are at so happy
to take questions
thanks richard councillors
first of all i'll move the reports
received if this is second
council thank you
do we have um
how long will it be until we've got a
more firm idea around the cost
of the entire cost for council at the
moment we know what the um
the vaccine mandate requirement cost us
which is around 90
i want to say 91 000.
um
so we have that in place in terms of the
cost the entire pandemic it's at the
moment distributed across a whole lot of
different areas of councils that would
be a separate bit of work to actually
determine what
a covert pandemic has cost us
just out of curiosity thanks richard
councillor partner
um
right just looking to the future that's
always a good thing to do
um with uh and the media there's talk
about a new variant already
it's got a couple of letters after it i
think it's a b and a or
um anyway regardless of what it's called
is this delegated authority
in place
if
we need to go back if someone decides or
will council
like it did last time
overrule the ce and do what it wants to
do or
how does that work
through mr g
at the moment we've suggested that as we
fingers crossed are heading towards a
lull or perhaps maybe the end of the
pandemic that will make sense if there
are any other
decisions need to be made in a short
term that is about reducing those
restrictions that we do it under
delegation and that tool and that
instrument is appropriate for that
however we've also signaled that if
something uh is
out of the box or about more
restrictions or any more sort of
restrictions on freedom or access to our
sites we will bring that back for
consideration uh to council so it's a
bit of a professional judgment thing but
i think we'll
finger in the air and know if something
needs to come back to this forum and
whether it's a high impact anything to
add to that could it need to be led by
central government because they brought
in the vaccination passport system in
the first instance which was the trigger
for discussion here at council mr chair
i'd point you to page 28 of board books
or page 3 of the report
and at the top of that page the current
delegation remains fit for purpose
however should decisions be required
that increase restrictions to council
services
or necessitate the consideration of
redeploying
max
i keep saying this maxine vax passes
uh mandated vaccination passes the issue
will be brought back to council i
personally feel that restricting
public access is a choice for elected
members and not for me
councillor sopa
thanks mr chair i was also going to
refer to page 28 because i think that's
the very sensible and pragmatic position
for this council to
take
of course we trust a professional people
if there's a very sudden
decision um to make that without
necessarily calling an extraordinary
meeting but for the longer term and let
us
face the fact that we are in uncertain
times
on the covert issue
and what may come out of
further variants etc
the
intention
for council to bring back
any further decision as indicated on
page 28 as the sensible course and i
feel very comfortable that we are
leaving
the delegation in place but with
if you like some restrictions on the use
of that delegation depending on the
seriousness of
events none of us which none of which we
can predict at the moment
thank you councillor any other questions
or comments
lindsey did you want to say something
there sorry
okay
uh need to move forward a second to
receive the report councillor sopa
councillor scout thank you through no
further comments i'll put the motion all
in favor
all right against
carried thanks richard thank you for
your time
that was all the recommendations
sorry is all the recommendations yes
uh
proposed road naming policy for adoption
there's something about horses and cats
but rhiannon welcome back
oh no sorry i beg your pardon
hey
the road naming policy has been
developed at the request of council
council has been using the australia new
zealand standard for rural and urban
addressing is the main framework to this
point
this policy has been developed to
incorporate these standards and provide
a framework for proposing road names to
preserve and enrich our district's
culture heritage and geography
this version has been put forward as an
interim policy as we continue to work
through
with the manufenua representatives to
create a list
of pre-approved todayo names that we can
publish
once we have this list
the proposal to council will be to amend
the policy so that one of the three
options put forward
for selection to be uh today our name
i'm happy to take any questions that the
counselors may have
counsellors open for comments or
questions counselor edmondson
thanks chair um this is really great to
see and
i think it's a really good place to
start for us for
uh having some more diversity in the
names that we give our streets so i'm
very happy to move these recommendations
thank you
is there a second
councillor
thank you
any other questions or comments
miss cook
so um thank you hayden and we've had
some
quite good discussions about this matter
um
really what i want to
add to
the or some background to some of the
comments that are in the paper
is that i was asked about
people's names particularly regarding
soldiers and things like that so you
will see something in there which says
that
along the lines of people being
consulted before you use people's family
names so they may be on a war memorial
that does not mean that the city should
actually be able to uplift that name and
use it to name a street
um there's real people and there's real
descendants attached to all those things
it's a very mighty way of looking at
things but
i think that i would encourage
us to look at that as a cautious
approach people may be flattered and
and want to do that but other people
for other people it brings pain and
other memories and
may not be seen quite so um
sympathetically so
i appreciated the fact that the
conversations were open and
um
real
and that you've incorporated a lot of
the things that
manifest did suggest and
not all of it was strictly speaking
about terrell but it was about how we
can be more inclusive and how we can be
a little bit more
um
innovative
in how we name the stress because there
are some things that are quite
duplicated in our current
naming conventions
in the southern area of new zealand and
hopefully some of this will avoid that
and how many fourth streets does maliku
actually need
particularly when two polytechs are both
on fourth street
but thank you i appreciated the work
that you have done and how it appeared
in the document it was
i felt quite
inclusive
thank you
thank you councillor emerson and
councillor scala's movements and second
as it's good to me we should probably
delete the word draft from
recommendation too
be comfortable with that
okay thank you
councillor soper thanks mr i just
thought i'd like to make the comment
that roll on the day when all three
proposed options are too real
thank you any other comments
if not we've got to move for insignia
i'll put the motion all in favor
all right against
carrie thank you for that
that brings us to the lg nz agm remits
michael welcome
curtis councillors
your worship
miss cook
um
this is a relatively
standard report one could say uh each
year there is an lg nz annual general
meeting and they invite you to provide
your remits this is the information on
how you can go about doing that
i'm happy to answer any questions
very succinctly but michael thank you
looking for a
mover and a second before the three
recommendations counselor sopa
councillor amundsen
with that are there any questions for
michael
being none i'll put the motion all in
favor
against
carried
the next item is the lg nz conference
attendance uh in amongst the
recommendations can i just see
clarification from mrs hadley do we need
to name his worship in there as well
uh you could for the purposes of
absolute clarity i think that would be
wise
i think the report actually acknowledges
that his worship
is able to it's in the body
i think it would be appropriate to make
sure that it's in the recommendations
so
uh does anybody uh have any or so first
of all looking for a mover and a
secondary run recommendation something
on that board thank you councillor scout
and
counselor abbott thank you
uh now open for for questions comments
feedback or otherwise
yes mr chairman worship i think uh
the issue of the mayor being able to
attend
the annual conference of
delegates
should be sacrosanct
the um
it's
it's been a sort of reduction of mural
responses
to a wide range of topics here
and it's been going on for some time
and
i feel obliged to
make a stand for the
uh
issue of who goes there and all right
things may have changed
i admit that and um
if we can find any other city with a
deputy mayor decides whether or not the
mayor can attend
then i'll willingly step down but i
would say that would be a highly
difficult
decision to make
thank you worship i think it's useful at
this point to point out that nobody
has questioned your ability to attend
this conference
well
council of soap within council of
partner
uh thank you mr chair i see that there
is
an invitation for other councillors who
might be interested in attending to
indicate that and i am therefore
indicating my interest in doing so
thank you
councillor partner
just returning back to what his worship
um
brought up
it was my understanding
in the many years that i've been on
council is that
the mayor is
automatically goes as the leader of
council
and i don't know
where he would um
get the impression that this has changed
counselor lush
yes just um
and now that council suffers just
because i am
not doing a full triennium
because i was elected during a
by-election am i still
entitled to attend this
it's open to any counsellor okay well
i'd like to indicate i'll be um
okay so that's uh in recommendation
three also includes the attendance of
councillors sopa and lush
ms cook
um a question please
recognising that manoa manifest reps
at this council are not elected they are
nominated by agreement
but
having observed that other councils have
taken
um
people as part of i know dcc apparently
did last year
took a person to represent manufa
whether they hadn't appointed anybody at
that point
um is there in a consideration that this
council should do the same
providing networking opportunities for
um
and experiences for those councils not
necessarily saying i want to go i just
wondered if it had been talked about and
what the possibilities were
no it hadn't yes there are so really
what i would need is an indication of
whether or not you wish to go
does it have to be today
it needs to be well we're putting
emotion actually mr chair
i'm sorry to be a nuisance but the
answer is yes because
this isn't in accordance with the
council's policy that it's adopted to
date it's stepping outside it that's
fine
uh but on that basis i think it needs to
be sorted you can always withdraw if you
decide not to attend oh then i will
indicate that um
i wish to attend and
look at my calendar
thank you so for clarity recommendation
three
is approving the attendance of
councillors sopa and lush and ms cook
and his worship
that's in the previous recommendation
counselor amanson just in light of that
i guess and given that there are
financial implications
do we need to consider the budget for
um
this because as has pointed out in the
report some councillors have already
spent their allocation for training and
are we going to exceed the budget and do
we need to take that into consideration
it seems like a question that needs to
be asked yep and one of the first things
that springs to mind is that two years
ago there wasn't an lg nz conference at
all it was all done online so the budget
budget across the trianium is still
intact as i understand it clear mr chair
we don't have the updated expenditure
attached to this
my comment would be that at this stage
of the triennium and given the
importance around training that was
applied to the working on working
together i think it would be
let's say unfortunate if we
took that approach now i think that the
incoming council needs to consider it
uh with greater depth
yes bearing in mind it is a real
challenge without having that camera
lindsey
i know and i've been everywhere on my
computer to places that i didn't
understand and i still can't get with
them go with the ipad it's got an
inbuilt one go ahead
um yes i just wanted to mention i think
i know the answer to this i have an
unspended budget it is available for
anybody that wants to go but i think we
decided that we couldn't use it before
not sure it was raised as to whether or
not a councillor was able to transfer
their budget to another councillor
that's not able to happen but overall
the pool from people who have not
attended like yourself remains available
and essentially that's what we'll be
drawing on in this instance
okay fine with that i'm happy with that
thanks for your question
any others
if not the recommendations are up behind
me it's been moved and seconded i'll put
the motion all in favor
against
carried thanks for that councillors and
that brings us on to the activities
report
trudy
uh
mr chair your worship uh liver and
cooked uh so i will point out a couple
of pieces of information from my area
before i hand over to my colleague mr
gibling
we note that
compared to last year there's been a 30
reduction in the number of customers
that are coming to see us in a
face-to-face face-to-face environment
this has been echoed through ilt as well
so it's that changing
customer demand
we also note that
we have still struggled with
complete compliance with the 20 business
days for non-notified resource consents
now this is actually i've reached out to
my colleagues at neighbouring councils
and across new zealand this is a similar
circumstance there is a
gap in the market for planners
and as myself and the ce discussed this
morning these are cyclical with career
paths and with jobs and we're seeing
this even with our contractors are
having the same issue with recruitment
for
planners in this space but our team are
doing the very best they can
and will continue to work hard towards
the time frames but we will not hit that
kpi for this financial year
and my final piece uh before i hand over
to mr gibbling is that we have seen uh a
decrease in the number of dogs being
impounded but a slight increase on the
number of owners that are choosing to
surrender their dogs for re-homing
and i understand that's due to financial
impacts
of
owning a pet so we are working very
closely with our rehoming agencies who
are also seeing this across the country
as well
thanks trudy and thank you for front
footing that issue
steve
thank you mr chair uh your worship
counselors
there's probably just three points i'd
like to pass on um firstly one is around
the library visitation statistics
we've made a note in there that those
statistics that we've got reflect visits
to the building
and doesn't truly reflect the engagement
or the level of engagement that actually
occurs with the library services and i
think
we've we've certainly seen this as one
of the results of covert
around how participation
and engagement has changed with the
community lockdowns forced us to act
differently and some of those behaviors
have caused us to react differently and
it's made it easier for some of our
services to be accessed online
so we will be looking at the next month
or two
to bring back to this committee
better engagement statistics around
library services because i know of all
the teams that i look after they are
certainly pushing that online service
portal a lot more
in regards to the museum aspect of this
report
i just want to touch on the collections
section which just to note for council
and this committee
that we're approximately 88
packed and ready for re-housed
with the smag
collection which is up from the previous
month's number
and that we remain on track for
september 2023 relocation so i know that
that was something we committed to bring
back to this committee about progress
i also want to identify as well that the
smag board last week considered the
first
significant round of de-accessioning
of
tonga and that passed through as well so
the team are pulling both levers in
terms of packing and de-accessioning the
collection and we'll be undertaking a
review of the collections policy as well
final point
in this was raised by councillor clark
at the last meeting is a quick update on
anderson house and we provided a quick
summary about where we are in that
process richard's here to answer any
questions but just to note that a full
and formal report will be coming to this
committee this time next month happy to
take any questions thanks richard
anything you want to add at this point
thank you
counselors open for questions or
comments at this stage
counselor sopa
just one comment i i think needs to be
made for completeness mr chair on page
75
there's a reference to a b quest from an
estate
so just for comprehensiveness i need to
declare that i am the executor of the
estate of elizabeth miller
i think it's an interest not a conflict
but that's an interest but i think it
needs to be noted steve just coming back
to the cataloguing of the smag
collection you said the figure sits at
88 percent
um i think it's probably worth pointing
out that the remaining 12 is
tricky
yes
as i've pointed out a couple of times
previously this is not an indication of
time
it's more an indication of total volume
uh and it's our ability to move our
collection from one position to another
and so
that's why we're also not only
indicating the percentage but the
estimated time of arrival
hopefully at our um the new facility so
uh
they both are relevant numbers and
certainly by september 2023 we will be
ready to go
thanks thanks for that clarification
again
too there are no questions or comments
i'll move that the reports received if
there's a seconder councillors amundsen
thank you
i'll put that all in favor
aye against
carried
uh folks that brings us to the end of
the uh open part of the meeting we'll
i'll move that we go into public
excluded for the receiving of uh minutes
as listed uh the
community wellbeing fund committee of
february 17 p.e from performance policy
and partnerships march 8 and an update
on the approach to the lgnz credit
contracts act
for the reasons as outlined in the
agenda is there a seconder for that
councillor scout thank you
i'll put that all in favor
against kerry thanks to those who've
joined on uh
online the stream will now finish